Hi.
I'm Curtis Lassam.
You can also find me on Twitter, I'm classam.
I work at a company called Sauce Labs, they
let me come to this conference without burning
holiday PTO, take a moment to take in this
slide, I produce cube drone.com, before I
start the presentation, JavaScript, very confidently
a couple of times, in case we get a DJ again
next year, JavaScript, JavaScript, JavaScript!!
Ok .
So this presentation is called HorseDrawingTycoon,
the world's best horse drawing simulator,
or how I turned the world's dumbest JavaScript
into time off work, yes my presentation full
title is 31 years long, that's how you know
you will get a lot of bang for buck, nobody
will offer this density, nobody that's who.
I'm from Vancouver Canada, VanJS is a small
meet up local to Vancouver, I'm talking with
a friend at the pub, he wants to make video
games, he has a bunch of ideas, they're all
really good, I took it upon myself to suggest
games that would never take on, like Breakout
where you play with bricks.
An indie game generator produced incredible
ideas, like a horror came where you ride horses
with Ninjas, or FGS where you stab researches,
these ideas too were obviously much too could,
I would play any of the games it described,
eventually it came to an idea so bad nobody
would ever want to play that game, a tycoon
game where you draw horses indefinitely it's
the worse idea for a game I ever heard, I
had to build it, in order to finish it before
everyone forget the bar conversation I had
to build it really quickly, obviously it didn't
need to be could, my VanJS companions had
many questions, questions like, how are you
going to build it, canvass.
How are you going to know people are going
to draw horses, isn't this just going to be
an obscenity drawing game, I would discover
the answers to these questions.
Although I did not at any point know that
the horse recognising artificial intelligence.
So before I go any further into this presentation,
I have to tell you this is an actual piece
of software that exists, I'll do a short demonstration
for you, HorseDrawingTycoon, I can stamp horses,
pick a colour, brush size, I can scribble,
it's got everything.
Ok.
This is a horse that somebody drew with HorseDrawingTycoon,
this application has been running uninterrupted
since I launched it, it's pretty 'Stable'!!
that brings us to chapter 2, canvass.
The most interesting part of a horse drawing
simulator would be of course the drawing part,
which gives me an opportunity to talk about
the HTML 5 canvass element the canvass tag
allows you to create an element in the DOM
you can draw horses on.
While I'm certain there may be other uses
for the canvass element, say video games or
stuff involving graphics I can't see how any
non-horse drawing use of canvass is worth
acknowledging, it exposes something called
a rendering context to the page's JavaScript,
it encapsulates all the actions you can perform
on the canvass, the entire canvass API, you
can get a rendering context with code that
looks like this.
Then, you can do stuff to the canvass element
using the API defined by the rendering context,
here we are drawing a rectangle that is blue,
note that we are specifying a 2 D context
here, is also has a 3 D rendering API, using
it for the horse drawing application might
be a bit out of scope the primary things to
draw are paths, rectangles, text and Bitmaps,
- this is the sort of tooling that lends itself
to building a game engine for a stupid horse
drawing application it's a little bit complicated
the create JS libraries are for building rich
content in JavaScript applications, PreloadJS,
SoundJS, between JS, EaselJS is the part we're
interested in, it allows us to work with the
HTML 5 canvass, it contains convenience methods
for working with a bunch of things like sprites,
blurs, buttons points and strokes, the bitmap
object is really useful for stamps, I don't
have much to say about stamps, if you dynamically
set the cursor and use a bitmap, we have horse
stamps, horse stamps in action.
Now stamps are all well and good this is of
course stamping is this is into stamping tycoon,
it's HorseDrawingTycoon, when figuring out
how to draw horses, I tried to draw a circle
under the pen while it detected a movement
while the user was clicking, the problem with
that, the mouse can move much quicker than
the sample rate of the browser, so instead
of flowing lines we get dots everywhere, the
first thing I tried didn't work.
We can connect those dots with
lines to complete the drawing, it works pretty
well, but fast movements will still result
in drawings with hard edges.
I remember the deviant art mirror simulated
covers by connecting lines to previous points
instead of just the last line, it was a beautiful
affect but not really what I was going for.
The technique I used was one I found in demo,
between every two points I created a mid-point,
when I reached the next point in the drawing
I create a quadratic curve from the last mid-point
to the next point, it's kind of complicated
in this draw.
Quadratic Bezier covers are more complicated
than they sound, here we are just curving
between the mid-point of the last slide to
the next point in our drawing, ending up creating
a nice smooth curve.
Here are some more horses that actual people
have drawn using HorseDrawingTycoon.
Ok, so we're done with canvass for now.
That's takes us to chapter 3, LucidJS, at
the VanJS presentation I just attended a talk
on Twitter's flight, a component shading event
driven framework, it was interesting in the
point of being my application as a collection
of components that send and receive events
appealed to me, flight itself wasn't the right
framework for me, months earlier I attended
a talk on LucidJS, pretty much the same thing,
but I was paying more attention during the
LucidJS, JavaScript has the own baked in events,
but we need to maintain separation between
elements like click and things like clear
canvass.
Let's look at a simple LucidJS event emitter,
we can create an emitter to manage events,
then we can combined function to an event,
we're binding it to the super awesome event,
then we can call the function by emitting
the function 0 come event, passing any events
to the function.
LucidJS that has a lot of functions above
and beyond a standard event emitter, you can
bind specific events to one another, name
space events so that only specific listeners
will receive those events and even create
meta listeners and listen on the very act
of binding itself.
HorseDrawingTycoon comfortably ignores all
of these features but they are all potentially
useful for larger applications.
So how is those better than defining global
functions and then calling them?
Well more than one function can be bound against
an event, the canvass function can behind
it to the current brush stroke, at the same
time the component that manages the cursor
could also behind to that event and change
the colour of the cursor when it receives
the change colour event.
Both components are responding separately
to the change colour event and neither of
the components needs to know about the other
or what the component is doing with the event.
The other benefit of the vent stream this
events become a stream of objects you can
manage, it's possible to see realise all events
and store them for later, keeping a complete
history of very event in your application,
or a component that listens for events that
change the application state and keep track
of it using local storage, that same component
could reemit the events when the application
boots up.
Now if that sounds like a needlessly convoluted
way to handle story in your application I
can assure you it is, that's how HorseDrawingTycoon
stores data and it's a bad idea.
One of the problems with this sort of implementation
the components can tie what ever they want
to an event, replaying those events we might
only want to trigger some of those effects,
there is no granular way to control them,
it's one of the places where more of the advanced
features would have come in handy like name
spacing for example, if I was to rewrite the
serialisation of HorseDrawingTycoon I probably
wouldn't have done it that way, I still think
events are awesome though.
One more time, yeah!
That ends our chapter on LucidJS, I have more
horses to fill the gaps between chapters.
Really cool horses.
!  .
It brings me to chapter 4, local storage.
When it comes to stashing things on the browser
side there are few options that are well supported,
web SQL that only works on Chrome and safari,
indexedDb that works in Chrome and sort of
safari, local storage that works absolutely
everywhere, but at the expense of being dumb
as a rock.
Actually the simplicity of local storage is
exactly what I'm looking for when building
such a simple application as HorseDrawingTycoon.
Let's look at the local storage API, you can
write to local storage with set item, everything
you write is saved against a key, in this
case we're saving the string JSConf, against
the key, hi, we can read from local storage
with get item.
When you write to local storage that data
sticks around every time the user returns
to your website on the same browser.
There are multiple ways to access local storage,
using get item and standard object interfaces.
Considering how the key, I don't exist, does
not in fact exist, all three of these calls
are going to fail.
In this case, because the key doesn’t exist,
x is no, but y and z are undefined, the different
ways of accessing local storage data operate
differently.
Another important thing local storage can
only deal in string data if you are dealing
with anything not a string you have to serialise
and deserialise, use JSON string and JSON
parse.
Self referential data structures, in JavaScript
self referential data structures like this
one right here, are unserialisable, there
are a few options for avoiding this, the first
is making it possible to realise - your other
options just not to write code that has a
cycle in it.
Another thing that to potentially concern
yourself with is what happens when you run
out of space in local storage, it varies from
browser to browser and per domain you might
have 2.5Mb, 5Mb or unlimited space, these
are the most common quotas, there are others.
If you go over your quota, your browser will
throw a quota exceeded error, I bet you are
excited to hear how I built my application
to cleverly avoid the problem of cyclical
data structures.
How I manage to keep my storage needs in check.
I completely ignored these things.
As it turns out in application as small as
mine it's easy
so that's chapter on local storage.
Chapter 5, horse rank one feature of my application
is that every horse drawing is run from a
complicated artificial intelligence algorithm
that ranks had horse like every image is.
It's much dumber than I make it out to be.
It's possible to use the get image data function
of a context to get raw data that's been displayed
on the screen as any given pixel.
The function produce and object, the object
have very, very
long array that containing red green blue,
each pixel takes 4 spaces in the array, information
is laid out 4 at a time in red, green, blue
and alpha for each pixel, alpha being a fancy
graphics word for transparency.
When you get to the end of the row it continues
with the next row with that established it's
super easy the his toe cram of the colours
that the player you had even display that
hest gram to the user so that the terrible
secret of horse rank has been revealed.
So, while we're talking about cool things
that we can do with the entire canvas, let's
talk about saving the users horse.
Which is actually really easy with the 2 data
URL function.
This function converts the whole canvas into
a URL, but a URL that contains all of the
data for the entire image encoded in base
64.
These strings are very, very long but they
contain all of the data of your entire image.
Just going to take a quick sip of this water.
These things are down right magic you can
just slap them into an image tag bam!
there's your image.
Once the image is serialised like this is
really easy to save, but it's also really
easy to Tweet.
Which brings us to chapter 7, secretly tweeting
every single thing the users draws.
If you navigate to Twitter.com/infinite horse
you will see a strong of every single horse
ever drawn with the application.
I will take you on a live tour if somebody
one has drawn an obscene horse in the lass
20 minutes I will shine an unpleasant light
on the presentation.
It works about how you imagine I. I am going
to leave the details of the server large unexplored,
this JavaScript built the server machinery
in python the whole thing fits into about
160 lines on Google app energy for free, it's
python it's not really what we want to call
the (inaudible) because I hosted the tweet
machinery on a different server I have to
make a cross origin request to save that tweet
which brings us to our chapter on CORS.
As you know making a request from one domain
to another is forbidden in JavaScript.
The first way to get round that the first
JSONP loads this theoretical horse drawing
application that might use JSONP.
You are always allowed to do this regardless
of the origin in this example we're visiting
the server horse.picks with the data foo there's
an error don't look too closely, the server
responds with a script that contains a call
back function that contains any requested
data to application.
In this example we're calling back with the
return data bar, this will call a function
you have defined globally, returning control
to your application with any data you have
requested.
JQuery will abstract most of these details
away from you if you tell to it make a JSONP
request to a server all you need to do is
make sure your server properly returns a call
back.
There is some problems with the strategy though
for one thing it's only capable of sending
get requests.
If you’re a reuqest fanatic the thought
of using it hurts you to very core on top
of that in order to fit our entire image,
our URL would have to be over 50,000 characters
long.
Theoretically there's no limit on URL size
many standards compliant servers browser start
to choke our about 2000 characters having
a crazy long URL will make logging very difficult.
It seems like a bad idea to use JSONP this
way which takes us to other strategy.
CORS.
CORS, or cross origin resource sharing is
a relatively new feature now supported in
all browsers.
It's really simple before making a call to
your browser it will check to receive your
URL returns a special access control allow
origin header
containing the domain you are now browsing
from or a while the card which will allow
the resource to from any script.
Once the browser has checked it’s ok it
will gladly lift the barriers of the same
origin policy for you.
So this again can be abstracted away with
a jQuery option as long as you spend 5 minutes
or so making sure you server supports it.
That's it.
That's all the technical detail I have for
you now let's look at some horse drawings.
Now you might imagine the distribution of
horse drawings might look like this.
5% actual horse drawings, 95% obscene
drawings but in fact after looking at a sample
of 100 horses the actual numbers look a lot
more like this with 11% incomprehensible scribbles,
23% recognisable horse which is a surprisingly
large number, 1% of obscene drawings, 30%
with some stamps and 36% with way too many
stamps.
It's really common for people to discover
the stamp tool right away then draw we something
that looks like this.
Some of the horses that were drawn were simplistic.
Minimalistic, other horses were complicated,
rich in detail.
some people were quite talented
at horse drawing.
This person seemed to have a lot of trouble
drawing a horse.
Their next drawing supported this theory.
some horses were magical, some
were fat, some people had trouble drawing
really compelling horses some horse artist
were very literal just writing the word horse.
Quite a few of them actually.
Horse yo.
I draw a horse, this one looks like an engineer
drew a horse.
One user went in a clever direction and actually
drew a horse drawing a tycoon.
another user drew me an ancient
cave painting.
I have many more interesting horses I could
show you.
There are over 2000 that have been posted
since I built the application, but after all
this talking, I am feeling a little hoarse.
Hah, hah another horse pun.
So that's the presentation.
I understand that I have thrown a lot of information
up on these slides so if you want to see anything
you have left you can get the whole slide
deck off of this URL.
There are also available from my home page
at Curtis.Lassam.net but my home page is served
out California it's not behind a CDN, the
whole presentation could take you several
days or years to actually load which is why
it put it up here behind my CDN.
Thanks for watching everyone.